las imágenes muestran el traslado de
Luis Fernando Camacho al penal de
chonchocoro el gobernador de Santa Cruz
La mayor y más rica región boliviana fue
sentenciado a cuatro meses de prisión
preventiva por cargo de terrorismo en el
marco del caso golpe de estado 1 la
defensoría del pueblo habló sobre su
situación hemos conversado también con
el director con el responsable de este
recinto penitenciario el mismo que está
habilitando un espacio para que el señor
Camacho pueda permanecer Durante los 14
días que va a estar en aislamiento
posteriormente seguramente incorporará a
la población en Santa Cruz Los
partidarios de Camacho respondieron un
paro de 24 horas con Cortes y
manifestaciones la oposición en las
calles sentencia estaba escrita y estaba
preparada incluso antes de comenzar la
audiencia es decir fue una sentencia por
encargo una sentencia dictaminada
políticamente por el presidente arce y
por el ministro de gobierno
pero también ciudadanos del común en la
principal región opositora el gobernante
movimiento al socialismo estamos en pie
de Lucha como pueblo Somos el pueblo que
estamos en pie no son
los somos nosotros el pueblo que estamos
en pie Luis Fernando Camacho lideró las
protestas de 2019 estas se produjeron
después de que parte de la oposición
acusará de fraude a Evo Morales este
terminó siendo derrocado Y tuvo que
salir del país del posterior gobierno
interino vivió las protestas más grandes
en años que dejaron 37 muertos en las
calles